[Aplausos]
[Música]
alguna vez os habéis parado a pensar que
le hace falta un país para ser
considerado una gran potencia mundial y
a colación de esta pregunta vosotros
pensáis que rusia es una gran potencia
mundial o mejor dicho pensáis que más
allá de su arsenal nuclear rusia cuenta
con los ingredientes necesarios para ser
considerada como tal hasta dónde es
capaz de proyectar su influencia
y ojo porque a pesar de todo lo que
hemos visto en la frontera
ruso-ucraniana la respuesta no es nada
sencilla son muchos los factores que
entran en juego pero para ostentar el
título de superpotencia parece claro que
hacen falta tres cosas primero capacidad
de intervención y disuasión militar
segundo influencia política e influencia
en los organismos internacionales y
tercero capacidad económica la pregunta
por tanto es cumple la rusia de vladimir
putin estos criterios
[Música]
en términos militares la federación rusa
es claramente una superpotencia hablamos
de la primera potencia por número de
ojivas nucleares desplegadas casi 1500
además rusia cuenta con unas fuerzas
armadas grandes relativamente bien
equipadas y sobre todo apoyadas por un
enorme complejo industrial-militar y
aunque no alcancen tecnológicamente el
nivel de desarrollo de occidente si
pueden decir que cuentan con un
armamento avanzado en segundo lugar la
influencia política y en organismos
internacionales también la tiene rusia
es uno de los cinco miembros permanentes
en el consejo de seguridad de la onu que
tienen derecho a veto el mismo estatus
que tiene en eeuu china reino unido y
francia-
sin embargo cuando hablamos de capacidad
económica o influencia política directa
más allá de su área de influencia
geográfica entonces la cosa cambia rusia
no tiene capacidad para castigar con
sanciones a terceros países no cuenta
con aliados importantes que puedan
seguir sus directrices y tampoco puede
emplear técnicas de guerra económica
además podemos contar con los dedos de
una mano los países que hoy por hoy
aceptan el liderazgo político de moscú
[Música]
i
ahora bien no penséis ni por un instante
que pretendemos descubrir la pólvora
para nada en el kremlin y el propio
presidente ruso son perfectamente
conscientes de esta realidad o más bien
de esta debilidad y precisamente por
este motivo llevan años tratando de
tejer su propia red de países aliados
países que le den a rusia influencia
internacional capacidad de liderar y
acceso a nuevos mercados y ojo porque no
hablamos de china la relación sino rusa
es sí muy importante fundamental para el
kremlin pero en moscú son perfectamente
conscientes de que en esa relación rusia
no es el país líder china les apoyará
cuando y como a la propia china le venga
bien ni más ni menos
[Música]
ahora bien cómo lograrlo cómo puede un
país como rusia tratar de construir esa
red de aliados hasta donde llegan los
tentáculos de moscú qué herramientas
utilizar a vladimir putin para expandir
la influencia rusa pues veréis desde que
asumió la presidencia en 1999 una de las
obsesiones del presidente ruso ha sido
llegar a controlar y rodearse de los
oligarcas que manejan las grandes
empresas del país en especial de las
empresas energéticas y sabéis que putin
lo ha logrado la mayoría de las grandes
empresas del país responden directamente
a los intereses del estado y lo hacen
hasta tal punto que frecuentemente se
convierten en la punta de lanza de la
mismísima política exterior rusa
[Música]
hablamos querida comunidad de un modelo
que tiene como cimientos los favores los
chantajes y los privilegios de todo tipo
prácticamente podemos decir que el
modelo de gobernanza rusa se basa en
algo así como en el 'toma y daca' en un
juego de favores acordado en un despacho
con las puertas cerradas queridos amigos
amigas en este vídeo vamos a ver cómo el
presidente ruso aprovecha el control que
tiene sobre los grandes oligarcas para
expandir la influencia rusa en el
extranjero esta es la espada menos
conocida de la diplomacia rusa atentos
[Música]
oligarcas la mano de putin
pongámonos en perspectiva la caída de la
unión soviética vino seguida de una
etapa de crisis y descomposición
política que alimentó un sueño casi una
obsesión entre buena parte de la
población rusa recuperar la grandeza el
poder y su influencia en el mundo porque
amigos la prosperidad económica la buena
marcha de las empresas o las
oportunidades profesionales son para
muchos ciudadanos rusos objetivos
secundarios lo primero de todo la
prioridad número uno es la fuerza la
influencia el poder de la madre patria
rusia
[Música]
y sabéis que desde su llegada al poder
las políticas de putin han tenido
exactamente esa misma perspectiva la
fortaleza nacional por encima de
cualquier otra cuestión pero claro
teniendo en cuenta todas las
limitaciones económicas que tiene el
país la pregunta la gran pregunta es
cómo demonios lograrlo cómo conseguir
influencia frente a los mismísimos eeuu
pues amigos lo que el gobierno de putin
ha hecho ha sido ni más ni menos que
intentar pescar precisamente en todos
aquellos países que no suscitan mucho
interés para las otras grandes potencias
un buen ejemplo reciente lo podemos
encontrar en agarrados a la silla en el
último gran fracaso de la política
exterior norteamericana por supuesto nos
estamos refiriendo al emirato islámico
de afganistán a día de hoy uno de los
países más pobres e inestables y
convulsos de todo el mundo y ahora rusia
ha fijado en su línea de tiro
[Música]
el terrorismo el yihadismo así como
algún que otro proyecto energético han
hecho que moscú mire directamente al
país de los talibanes entre otros
motivos porque una de las cosas que más
aterroriza moscú es que este país se
convierta en un epicentro del yihadismo
en una base de operaciones para grupos
radicales no olvidemos que rusia tiene
un problema creciente con esta cuestión
gran parte de la antigua unión soviética
se ha convertido en terreno fértil para
la radicalización yihadista y de hecho
en rusia no sólo viven más de 20
millones de musulmanes sino que este
llegó a ser el país que más combatientes
extranjeros aportó al issys
[Música]
pues bien con todo esto en mente tras la
huida de eeuu moscú sintió la necesidad
de ganar influencia así como monitorizar
y vigilar de cerca lo que ocurre en el
emirato islámico de afganistán pues bien
para lograrlo el gobierno de putin ha
echado mano de su agenda de oligarcas
amigos oligarcas que tienen nombres y
apellidos y hablamos sobre todo de uno
que destaca por encima de todos los
demás yevgueni prigoshin este hombre es
propietario tachán tachán de los
restaurantes favoritos del presidente
ruso motivo por el cual se le conoce
como el chef de putin
amigos trigo zinc es un estrecho aliado
de putin y dedica una parte de su
fortuna a financiar actividades
políticas y paramilitares en el exterior
hablamos de uno de los actores más
poderosos en los círculos políticos de
rusia uno de los oligarcas más
importantes del país ni gas ni petróleo
ni carbón restaurantes bueno
restaurantes y también mercenarios
yevgueni prigoshin es algo así como un
representante del kremlin en la sombra
el tipo al que se le confían las
misiones que el gobierno ruso no quiere
que sean oficiales un personaje que goza
prácticamente del monopolio a la hora de
proyectar las ambiciones de rusia hacia
oriente medio y áfrica a cambio claro
está de perseguir su propio beneficio
vamos un win win en toda regla ahora
bien una pregunta que seguro seguro
muchos os estáis haciendo como trabaja
como proyecta su influencia pues veréis
prigoshin es el creador del grupo wagner
[Música]
el grupo wagner es una organización
paramilitar que cuenta con una red
internacional de mercenarios y negocios
poco limpios que operan en países donde
no nos gustaría ir de vacaciones el
grupo wagner ha desplegado fuerzas
paramilitares en países como siria libia
sudán e incluso se le relaciona con la
invasión de ucrania de 2014 y no sólo
eso también se les atribuye
intervenciones en países amigos de rusia
para sofocar protestas pro-democracia
realizar todo tipo de campañas de
desinformación y operaciones de bandera
falsa este grupo fue por ejemplo acusado
de interferir en las elecciones
estadounidenses de 2016 e incluso se
dice que este grupo también se dedica a
la extracción de oro y diamantes muy
probablemente de minas ilegales
vamos que no son precisamente una ong y
una empresa a la que le preocupe la
responsabilidad social corporativa los
dos criterios es eje o vamos cualquiera
de esas cuestiones por supuesto que
brady prigoshin es uno de los oligarcas
sobre los que pesan sanciones de los
eeuu y si podríamos llegar a decir que
rusia tiene algo así como dos
ministerios de asuntos exteriores y dos
ministerios de defensa está en lávrov
cybook como ministros formales y trigo
zinc como el encargado de operar en la
sombra pues el caso es que este oligarca
ruso es también el principal financiador
de la fundación para la protección de
los valores nacionales la fceh está en
efe
[Música]
la fundación para la protección de los
valores nacionales es una organización
con presencia en varios países de áfrica
y asia central en el caso de afganistán
hombre de confianza en el terreno maxim
su ley fue una de las primeras personas
en llegar a kabul después de que los
talibanes se hicieran con el poder su
gale y control a una red política
dependiente de la fct nc que busca
encontrar áreas de cooperación en
materia de seguridad y también
económicas entre los talibanes y rusia
buscar áreas de cooperación y por
supuesto estar al tanto de todo lo que
ocurra en el país
[Música]
y ojo porque no hablamos de cualquier
tipo sino de uno muy experimentado por
ejemplo llegó a ser encarcelado en libia
desde julio de 2019 hasta diciembre de
2020 por haberse reunido con saif
al-islam gadafi un hijo del exlíder
libio para animarle a que diera el salto
a la primera línea política ahora bien
que quieren exactamente putin prigoshin
y su ley de los talibanes
[Música]
pues bien una de las consecuencias
directas que ha tenido el ascenso al
poder de los talibanes es el aislamiento
internacional del país son muy pocos los
países que quieren tener lazos con el
afganistán actual así que si los
talibanes quieren obtener dinero armas
energía o información para consolidar su
poder que mejor que recurrir a los oros
o el pasado pasado está pero que puede
sacar rusia de un lugar tan inhóspito
empobrecido y desolado como afganistán
puede convertirse en el actual
extranjero más influyente de todo el
país y os preguntaréis y para qué
demonios quiere esa influencia en un
país tan desolado pues por ejemplo para
impedir que afganistán se convierta en
una base de operaciones para grupos
yihadistas que moscú considera una
amenaza pero eso no es todo moscú
también persigue lo que podríamos
denominar como objetivos de
geoestrategia económica ahí estarían los
enormes yacimientos de minerales
estratégicos como el litio que tiene
afganistán pero también hablamos de
proyectos estratégicamente tan
importantes como éste
lo que veis en pantallas del proyecto
tapping un enorme gasoducto que una vez
se complete permitirá transportar
enormes cantidades de gas desde
türkmenistán hasta la india y pakistán
hablamos de por lo menos 33 mil millones
de metros cúbicos de gas anuales en una
primera fase el régimen talibán
desplegará a 30.000 soldados para
reanudar las obras del proyecto del
gasoducto tapi pero eso no es todo
fijaos de nuevo en el mapa
afganistán podría llegar a convertirse
para la india y pakistán dos países que
suman más de 1600 millones de habitantes
el 20 por ciento de la población mundial
en lo que durante años ucrania ha sido
para la unión europea esto es un enclave
estratégico
indispensable para recibir un enorme
caudal de gas natural y petróleo desde
los ricos yacimientos de asia central y
sabéis que los rusos llevan años
queriendo formar parte de este negocio
fijaos roo se interesara en participar
en la construcción del gasoducto tapi y
la pregunta es por qué diantres le
interesa tanto a rusia pues
fundamentalmente por dos motivos en
primer lugar rusia es un enorme
exportador de petróleo y gas natural
participar en la que puede llegar a ser
una de las rutas más importantes del
mundo reforzaría mucho su influencia
energética y en segundo lugar de
consolidarse esta ruta rusia podría
llegar a utilizarla en el futuro para
exportar su propio gas y petróleo y ojo
porque las estimaciones apuntan a que la
india de morada a gas y petróleo durante
los próximos años y creedme cuando os
digo que los rusos están como locos por
buscar clientes alternativos a las
economías europeas pero también a china
la ruta afgana y la conexión con la
india podrían ser una vía para conseguir
un nuevo cliente gigantesco en esta
línea el gasoducto tapi podría ser
ampliado y eventualmente conectado a los
campos de extracción de gas que rusia y
kazajistán están desarrollando en el mar
caspio
hablamos de los campos de central no hay
más escoge una y un 21 entre el
principal productor de gas kazajo la
kazmunaigas national company y un
consorcio ruso formado por lukoil y
gazprom ambos países tienen una
participación en el proyecto del 50% y
para gazprom por ejemplo estos campos
serán su mayor apuesta en el mar caspio
[Música]
quién iba a pensar que un territorio tan
paupérrimo y desolado como afganistán
podría ser potencialmente tan importante
pues para asegurarse de que todo está
bajo control ahí están los oligarcas
rusos contando sus redes de influencia y
vigilancia por todo el país a cambio los
talibanes reciben armas asesoramiento
energía suministros de diverso tipo e
incluso llegado el caso dinero el
paquete completo de rusia ahora bien no
pensáis ni por un instante que este es
el único ejemplo que vamos a poder
encontrar basta con echar un vistazo al
continente africano y también a
latinoamérica para encontrar mucha
actividad por parte de moscú atentos
el catálogo ruso
si la influencia de eeuu y sus aliados
occidentales es muy pero que muy grande
pero también es cierto que en algunos
lugares es mucho más limitada que en
otros no es ningún secreto y es algo de
lo que ya os hemos hablado aquí en
visual político la influencia de china
en áfrica se ha disparado en los últimos
años mediante inversiones construcción
de infraestructuras acuerdos comerciales
o transferencias de tecnología el
gobierno chino ha ganado mucha
influencia y también nuevos clientes y
nuevos proveedores para sus empresas
pues bien en cierto modo rusia está
intentando hacer algo muy similar claro
que por mucho que le pese a putin rusia
no es china moscú no tiene ni de lejos
la cartera tan llena como pekín así que
al kremlin le ha tocado buscar otras
fórmulas digamos más imaginativas para
abrir ese paso
en el caso de áfrica rusia aspira a
convertirse en un importante proveedor
de cereales medicamentos y energía en
esta línea por ejemplo con más de 75
millones de toneladas anuales rusas y el
mayor exportador de trigo a egipto
también quiere aprovechar su amplia
experiencia para impulsar proyectos
mineros y energéticos en países como
zimbabue angola burkina faso
os acordáis del bueno de yevgueni
prigoshin el chef de putin pues se
conoce que sus empresas han recibido
concesiones para explotar diamantes y
oro en la república centroafricana otro
ejemplo sérguei ivánov hijo del ex
ministro de defensa ruso es el director
ejecutivo de 'la rosa' una empresa
minera rusa especializada en diamantes
porque amigos quizás rusia no tenga
tanta capacidad económica como china o
eeuu pero si tiene algo que muchos
gobiernos autocráticos desean armas
pocos escrúpulos y mucha experiencia en
materia de inteligencia represión y
seguridad
por ejemplo os acordáis del grupo wagner
que hemos comentado antes pues fijaos en
los últimos años se han desplegado
contratistas del grupo wagner en todo
oriente medio y áfrica incluidos siria
yemen libia sudán mozambique madagascar
república centroafricana y malí se han
centrado principalmente en la protección
de las élites gobernantes y las
infraestructuras críticas federica saint
y fasa no tía analista de brookings
institution además los rusos y los
chinos son muy pragmáticos nos preguntan
por cosas como los derechos humanos la
democracia o el medio ambiente y eso en
este tipo de países es una ventaja a la
hora de hacer negocios pues bien sabéis
que el modus operandi es muy similar al
que hemos visto en afganistán los
oligarcas rusos se establecen en el
terreno y buscan acuerdos con los
gerifaltes locales gerifaltes que
reciben cosas tan importantes para
mantener su poder como acceso al
catálogo completo de la industria
militar con sección especial de
mercenarios la experiencia la tecnología
y el know-how que necesitan para poder
explotar sus recursos naturales a cambio
rusia consigue e influencia política
nuevos clientes y también por supuesto
enriquecer aún más a los oligarcas
cercanos al kremlin
[Música]
desde libia hasta nigeria y desde
etiopía hasta malí durante los últimos
años moscú ha cerrado más de 20 acuerdos
militares a lo largo y ancho de todo el
continente africano algo que le ha
permitido a rusia convertirse en el
mayor exportador de material militar
para áfrica para que os hagáis una idea
su cuota de mercado rota casi el 50% 7
de septiembre en el 2021 rusia está
construyendo su influencia militar en
áfrica desafiando el dominio
estadounidense y francés 2 de octubre de
2021 el plan de malí para que
mercenarios rusos sustituyan a las
tropas francesas se inquieta el sahel
quiere unos amigos amigas más allá de
ucrania y los grandes titulares así es
como moscú intenta incrementar su
influencia política en el mundo al
tiempo que logra nuevos mercados para
sus productos e incluso más importante
consigue los dólares que sus empresas
militares necesitan para seguir
mejorando sus equipos esta es la fórmula
que rusia utiliza para seguir teniendo
toda la influencia que una superpotencia
necesita y en esta fórmula los oligarcas
y las grandes empresas rusas juegan un
papel clave allí donde occidente no mira
china y también rusia suelen tener al
menos un pie puesto en el terreno pero
llegas hasta aquí turno para ti qué te
parece la apuesta rusa por extender su
influencia de la mano de oligarcas
cercanos al kremlin déjanos tu opinión
aquí abajo en los comentarios y si te
resulta interesante este vídeo no
olvides darle al botón de like i
suscribirte a visual política una vez
más gracias por estar ahí un saludo y
hasta la próxima
[Música]